listen to law enforcement follow the law
follow the law follow police maintain
the peace between a few dozen right-wing
anti-migrant protesters you swam the
river sweetheart I didn't and a few
dozen border residents who said migrants
should be welcomed usually people just
want food and water and a clean pair of
socks sometimes when I find people they
get down on their knees and they ask for
God to bless
me but this wasn't the only standoff off
in Eagle Pass Texas on Sunday meters
away and steps from the US border Texas
governor Greg Abbott declared his
State's opposition to the federal
government and we are here to send a
loud and clear message that we are
baning together to fight to ensure that
we will be able to maintain our
constitutional guarantee that states
will be able to defend against any type
of imminent danger or invasion flanked
by 14 other Republican Governors Abbott
is an open Defiance of a US Supreme
Court order issued last month commanding
that he stand down Texas National Guard
troops who are putting up barbed wire
and blocking US border patrol Agents
from removing it the troops guarding
this section of the Border report to the
governor of the state of Texas and their
mission is to keep everyone out
including the US border patrol agents
who report to president Biden in
Washington and that has created an
absurd standoff between the federal and
state
governments why on Earth would Governor
Abott be doing this defying a US Supreme
Court order putting National Guardsmen
and border patrol agents at odds and
potentially in danger endangering the
lives of Asylum Seekers calling
right-wing militants from all across the
country with long guns down to a park
that they take over with without telling
City authorities I mean why would you do
that the Texas governor says a loophole
in the US Constitution allows him to
take such measures because his state is
under quote Invasion by migrants
arriving in record numbers Democrats
call it a political stunt meant to stoke
the Republican base the opposing sides
remain at an impass as tensions rise and
divisions
Harden Heidi Joe Castro Al jazer Eagle
Pass Texas
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz